what's up guys welcome to the just
pearly things youtube channel um today
i decided to do something kind of fun um
i'm doing a messy house tour
because i don't feel like cleaning
before this the house is huge
but i'm going to show you the outside of
the house oh oh not the dogs this dog
literally always tries to run not today
not today satan okay
so i'm gonna show you the front of the
house so i wish i could like be in these
videos but i could not find a sibling
that felt like
watching me walk around the house all
day but yeah this is one side of the
house
and then i walk over there to that side
of the house
i'm gonna take you guys with next we got
like this side of the house
and this is like where i parked my car
over there and then
speed this up here you can see so this
is like the backyard
um playground um
two trampolines i'm gonna show you
that's the shad random man walking
around my backyard
and i don't know who he is i'm about to
confront him let me grab my shoes
hmm he's like casually got a dirt bike
oh that might be the neighbor is that
zach
i think it's the neighbor let me just
assume it's probably fine
yeah all right well okay i guess he's
grown up now we go to like the backyard
part of the driveway i'm over here
those are the chickens um they scare me
i'm not even gonna lie sometimes they
chase me
um oh my god the rooster he's looking at
me weird
so a little trampoline
all this stuff cars so this is like the
back of the house
um it's like a porch there
another porch there crazy thing is i've
been wanting to make this video for
months but i could never find anyone to
film it
and i was just like you know what effort
i'm just filming on my own
um okay yeah so back of the house
there kind of kind of cool i turned the
camera around to the front
and we got
the pond so we actually own like
all of this land it's like 40 acres i'm
not gonna give you a full property tour
because
quite honestly it's too much
too much walking really this is the pond
you can go like paddle boating um
my dad like digs dirt with that machine
over there i don't really know what it
does
um there's the ducks what up guys
and we basically just have this like
island i honestly never walk here
because there's absolutely no point
um in the middle of the pond
my dad built whatever that thing is i
think it's for the ducks maybe
god only knows this is like a far view
of the shed
we're gonna go there next before i show
you the house
that'll be after okay so just so you
guys know i'm gonna tell you this as i'm
walking to the shed
the shed has been promised for years
like ever since i was a kid they told me
we were going to have the shed it was
going to have a bowling alley a shooting
range
all this stuff um you know no complaints
because clearly like
we were fine um but
but finally my dad starts building this
shed like a year ago
and it's basically going to be like
a guest house i'm going to show you but
it's not
done it's like still being built so this
is the chicken house i'd show you the
inside but it's literally absolutely
disgusting and i won't put you guys
through that
that used to be a sandpit but like
everyone's old now so no one's used it
in years
oh god i dropped the phone okay um
this is my dad's garden that's like
clearly no one's really taken care of
okay we're almost there okay we're going
into this baby
i have no idea how far they've come on
it i have not been inside of here in a
minute
okay i don't think there's actual like
lights because
well it's not done so i think this
part's supposed to be like a
a bull uh like the guest house part
maybe i don't even know
uh this is gonna be like a full-length
basketball court with three like half
basketball courts on the side
um see this shit's huge
let's see
kind of kind of nervous this is like
where you get killed in the horror movie
um okay
you know why i'm scared nobody's here um
this is gonna be a shooting range i
believe
um people have asked if i helped build
this at all and the answer
is no every time my dad asks me to help
he like basically fires me for the day
because i'm so unhelpful and not useful
okay can you guys see okay let's see if
i can open this garage so there's like
light
[Music]
oh god
okay yeah oh god okay
so this is like the i don't know machine
type of thing four-wheelers
um this is where we keep all the like
four-wheeler stuff too for now i don't i
think that'll stay the same because
these are garage doors
so utvs four-wheeler
utv four-wheeler and then like to be
honest
i seriously don't know what any of this
stuff does
um but i think my dad's gonna sell it
at some point when he's done with this
so if anyone needs any of this stuff
hit me up in six months
okay let me go to the outside
so this is like the back of that you see
how far the property goes
that's i have no idea what those trucks
do
another tractor thing um
yeah this is the back side of the
property
am i boring you guys sorry if this takes
forever
it's just like for real this property is
so big doing like a full tour
i can't even imagine doing like if i
included the trails and [ __ ] out here
i'm good on that i'm good
but okay
let me close the garage
close that
[Applause]
okay
see i wish i had like a camera crew
but i'm cheap i don't i don't really
pay people like that okay
i'm gonna turn the camera so this just
sort of gives you an idea of what we're
dealing with i'm excited to show you
guys the shed once it's done though
because it's gonna be really
cool
so funny thing people always ask to get
my dad on the channel
because you know he's like so wise and
successful i talk so highly of him and
you know whatever
but my dad hates social media like my
dad is the most
interesting person one of the most
interesting people i've ever met like
one he's never drank in his life so he
had one sip of alcohol
at the world series it was a angry
orchard and he thought it was so gross
so he's never drank um he met his wife
when he was like 22
23 i forget but like young right married
young
had a million kids
and yeah never had social media so
he's just someone who really doesn't
like to be like bothered
but then he had me and i bother him all
the time
it's cool though i'm gonna show you the
rest of the house okay so if you go in
the door this is the garage
jesus oh my god
did i climb let me close that door okay
these dogs are demons i spent half the
morning
chasing them around but sorry this is
the
garage let me see if i can go out a
little more
so this is the garage one thing people
find really cool
is this shoe wall so with all the kids
everyone has those shoes so we put them
on that wall this is just like
a typical bathroom um
not special at all
so this is a laundry room this is a
laundry chute so when you're on the
second floor you can put it down the
chute and it'll come to the first floor
there's my dog ellie um this is just for
like
when we get home from school as kids
we'd all hang our backpacks up there
um coats people think this is really
interesting
one thing about my mom is my mom is
crazy organized
okay so my phone died for a second i had
to go charge it so it's a little darker
but i'm gonna still give you guys like
uh
the rest of the tour okay so as i was
saying earlier um
this is like our hats um
gloves whatever laundry room
kind of cool thing um my mom's like
she'll fold the laundry here
put it up there and then we got
these are like um
these go to the laundry chute that was
over there so we like
push them over there and then the
laundry will like
fall and into the baskets um
two washers and dryers obviously excuse
like a million kids
i mean everyone's like older now but you
guys get it
okay so i told you what this was
now i'm cooking dinner actually right
now but this is the kitchen
so these are always like the best chairs
to sit in growing up
oh my god what is this dog doing i'm
afraid i'm not gonna like it what are
you eating
okay yeah so this is the kitchen it's my
dog ellie
again we i did not clean before this so
my mom is gonna be bad that i
am doing this video um but this is like
the normal dining room table so
whenever we have like you know it's
like not all 10 kids are here we sit
here it's like more the casual dining
room table
and then over here this is like the
great room so i'll play piano over there
um it's kind of cool because it's got
like crazy high ceilings
um dog okay then
this is like literally one of my
favorite rooms in the house so
it's got the like balcony and the two
stairwells growing up this is where we'd
always take like our homecoming pictures
and whatever um this is my dad's
office um it's like pretty basic
just like papers on the desk office
little fireplace
there keep on going
i don't know what they've got going on
in the dining room but this is
when we have like fancy dinners or like
christmas easter when like everyone's in
town we sit here
um but since there's such like a wide
age gap we don't use this room a ton
but i think it's like pretty um i think
this is like new tile for one of our
other houses these are just like
pictures
of our family so like that's my older
brother austin
that's baby me there's us together um
this is a young my parents when they
were young
but you guys you guys get the deal
um so this is like the butler's pantry
so
like tools um fine dining up there
and then if we ever have to like fix
something we like put it there
let me turn on turn on the living room
um so this is like the tv room
and it's actually really small because
my
dad changed the entire layout of our
house
to put in this stairwell so we could
play this game
called search and rescue where it's like
you go from the top floor to the
basement
okay um
other thing i didn't show you here's the
balcony so this is nice
because i could do like a little
romantic
sit down whatever and then you get a
view of the backyard which is kind of
nice
okay dogs come here come here dogs come
here
come on get out okay
so then we're gonna go
to the back bedroom so
oh this is the bar so like if we're
drinking or like doing stuff
this is we got the wine glasses
other stuff oh i love this piano too let
me wipe off
okay i love this piano literally
obsessed with it
um bookshelf here my mom's a big reader
a lot of my siblings are readers not me
more pictures this is just like a basic
basic little bathroom nothing like
special these are the guest rooms
um growing up this was the nanny room
but we don't have a nanny anymore so
now it's just a guest room it's got like
a
a walk-in closet not much in there
obviously a little desk
there um bathroom so this is nice
it's got like the sit down
toilet
um this is the other guest room so they
like share a bathroom
and my sister stays here because i took
my sister's room because like
she's at college right now
so again another cute little porch
um
dog come on come on dog
dog come on um and i really like that
there's a fireplace in this room it's
really nice
plus we have trundles let me show you
trundles
under like a ton of the beds in case we
have guests so this house can literally
fit so many people okay
done with that
come here okay
um okay now i should show you
the um i'm gonna do the
downstairs first and then show you the
upstairs
oh my gosh i'm gonna lock the dogs out
okay so here
we got the theater
and the cool part about the theater is
it's got like row here row there
row there and all of the movies
let me show you are here but the cool
thing about this is it actually
goes to be like a secret door and i'll
show you where it goes later
okay and this is the basement
my mom is redoing one of the rooms down
here so that's why there's all this
random stuff
but this is like a cool place to like
chill
just in the basement hang out we got a
peloton
right here i don't play billiards
billiards i don't even know
but this is fun you can play pac-man on
that in a bunch of other arcade games
um we got the treadmill i forgot what
that machine's called
kickboxing um a little workout area
um
air hockey and
foosball there so kind of cool
this is one of my brother's rooms
so this is the it's like a ferrari
themed
so it's kind of nice little area
we got here kind of cute
okay moving on this is my mom's office
but it's not done that's why all this
random stuff is out here
so she's got like
random it's gonna be like a a studio for
like recording and stuff
wow that's nice okay um
and then this
is a guest room slash paint room so
that can be like folded into the wall
and then there's like painting over here
so my sisters are still like young and
they live here like my
it's like 17 and 14 maybe i forget
tv there painting what the cool thing is
cool thing is this is the secret like
passageway so it opens
shoot and that goes into the theater
it's kind of hard to see but you'll just
have to
take my word
um okay let me go back upstairs
oh actually i'll show you
okay okay yeah okay this is just the
roller skate room so it's literally just
like
storage like this is our atv
collection rollerblades um we lowkey
have a pig
in here like they literally just buy
pegs and put it in that freezer
um
and this is my dad's garage so we have a
couple garages
but so again utvs
four-wheelers lawnmower
maybe guys would find this more
interesting but it's just like random
stuff to me
my dad's like tool area
i don't know this is my dad's space
okay so i think the coolest part
of the house is actually the upstairs so
i'm excited to show you guys that
this house tour would be so much cooler
if i had someone
to help me hold the camera but we do
what we can let's hear the chickens
coming
i got some time i got some time let's go
upstairs
um so i'm in the upstairs
hallway
so let me see so like over here
you can like see everywhere in the house
which is kind of nice
and then over here
we are in the master bedroom
so this is like
what my this is my parents room
sorry let me do a better view over here
maybe you can see
hey they like to poop on that carpet
sometimes
um this is like the extra room don't
even know what they used this for this
was amelia's like the baby room growing
up look how cute she was
um but yeah they don't need that anymore
um
this is the bathroom
so we got see if i can get a better view
of everything
let's see we got the up
and the down
and then the coolest part in my opinion
is the shower
like it's literally the nicest shower
i've ever showered in in my life nothing
will compare ever
so it's got like shower head there
shower head there shower head there my
mom's
like catholic so she's into like a
saints and like angels and stuff so
you'll see that
all over our house we got this bathtub
here
which is super nice because we have i'm
gonna step back so you guys can see it
better
but it's super nice because you got like
the windows there
and then you got like a private
bathroom here
um this is supposed to be closed
okay yeah so then you got the full
mirrors here
this stuff and then
this is my mom's closet and my dad's i
guess but he doesn't really count
um which is so nice like literally the
nicest closet
ever and what's really nice is having
like
these drawers you can like take in and
out and readjust
and she also organizes literally
everything as you can see
yes this is this is the parents room
we're done with this
okay next we're gonna go to the brothers
rooms
so
oh my god i hate these dogs
i just cleaned up the little terrorist
um
so he's got a tv there cool thing about
this room is it's cubs theme
so let me hold the phone the other way
so we got like the fans there my mom
painted this when she was like
pregnant we got let me
zoom out a little more oh yeah okay so
we got the fans there
we got the take me out to the ball game
if you're from chicago
you already know what that is um
his little gaming setup
um excuse that again i did not tell my
siblings i was filming this video
then there's a ladder to the loft that
used to be like a computer area but
now since everyone's older we just
really use it for storage
so
then we're moving into my other brother
adam's room so it's like this shit's a
castle
again nobody knew i was filming this
um i guess he was cleaning his sheets or
something but he's got the one bed there
oh my god the one bed up there
um it's kind of cool cause it's like an
actual
actual window we got like a little space
it's funny because my mom actually said
adam could have redecorated this
and he literally said no
so this is like
a fake window that my mom painted
there's a tree and a dragon
um there's his closet
um this used to hold his legos and stuff
but i don't think he has them anymore
and then his upstairs is actually kind
of cool oh god
going up this ladder with one
so he's got like a little man cave
um yeah so let me see if the light can
turn on
um yes this little man cave
this is just again this is my other
brother's loft so they all connect
so this is a mess but we literally just
use this for storage
and then this
is my room so this is where i shoot
sometimes i'll shoot content on that
couch
over there let me just give you like a
or i'll play guitar there's my stairway
down and i'm going to go there in a
second
but this is my studio
so that chair goes over here sometimes
and then this is where i
shoot all my content and it's kind of
cool because
one thing that you guys don't know this
is going to be kind of creepy
but this curtain is like a secret tunnel
for dolls my mom
won't let me get them out of there and
redecorate it so i said whatever
but yeah this is
and this curtain closes so
i don't know why but if i wanted privacy
i could like close it
just pearly things jpt
and then i go down the stairs
and i go to my room and this
is i was cleaning this today but this is
my room it's like pretty empty
because i'm really not i wasn't supposed
to be here very long
i have this window seat where i can look
out over the backyard
um but yeah so this is
and this is my bathroom i really like
like having this sit down area
i also have like a walk-in closet
so i have this area
and then this is my shower
and this is the room i actually grew up
in yeah so wait
i think you guys get the gist right
okay so next
we're going to go
and show you the boys rooms i'm almost
through this tour
this is let me turn the lights
this is the boys bathroom so we got the
tub there
we got the bathtub there
we got mirror there
so the boys all share this one i was the
only one growing up that got my own
bathroom because
well i'm the favorite that goes down to
the tv room
oh so this is a cool bathroom because
i'll show you why
so do you guys remember the laundry
chute that we went to downstairs
huh that's me okay we got sink
shower there so that my two youngest
sisters share this
that's just an attic for storage but
over here
is the laundry chute so i can like
throw a laundry down there and it goes
to the basement
okay other sisters rooms this is eva's
room
so it's the biggest one
um clearly she's got like a plant
addiction
um we're all really scared for her but
you know it is what it is there's her
bed so it like goes in here
and then she's got my mom won't let her
redecorate
um the clouds
and then this is just used for storage
so you know that
and then her closet's actually pretty
clean look at that
um yeah that's her closet
and lastly
lastly let's see
we have um amelia has this room now but
it was gabrielle's growing up so there's
that
same concept with the
bed overlooking
the backyard once upon a time
and then we got this like
um that's what's in this castle
so you'll see that's the castle
um i think that's like the art area
and then she's so cute she's got a
twitch um i should put the link in the
description because she's actually
probably my funniest sibling
and this is her closet
and i think that's everything guys
that is the full house tour i've done
one before but it was with my mom so
this is like
one i'm doing with my own spin on it so
sorry if it wasn't perfectly filmed
i'm not a budget but thanks for watching
um
i'm doing memberships on my channel with
like exclusive content so if you guys
want to be a part of that
sign up it's only five bucks a month
like literally a coffee
and i am excited to talk to you guys
next time